Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Here in the confusion of the streets, where a new sense of purpose is coming to be born. Here among the anonymous mass of working, suffering, thinking, silent people. Here in the midst of exhaustion and hope, justice and mockery, here in this shapeless mass, the driving force of a capital city, nerve center, and engine of a great American country. Here she is, the woman. So that was the introduction to a radio program called,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这里是喧嚣的街道，一种新的使命感正在此孕育。这里有成千上万默默无闻、辛勤劳作、饱经苦难、沉思默想而又沉默寡言的人们。这里交织着精疲力竭与满怀希望、正义与嘲弄，这里是无形的人潮，是一座首都的驱动力、神经中枢，是一个伟大美洲国家的发动机。她来了，这个女人。以上是一档名为
brilliantly, The Soldier's Revolution Will Be the Revolution of the Argentine People. Very Radio 4 title there. Great title. I tune in. And that was broadcast on Argentine radio, obviously, on the 14th of August, 1944. And the program was kind of dramatizing instances of poverty out in the reaches of Argentina. So it will be listing TB statistics and illiteracy and undernourishment. And the woman in this was played by Ava Duarte, who is the subject of our ongoing series, better known as Evita, and in due course to become Ava Perron. And in the course of this radio program that is broadcast, she speaks at the very end of the program. And Eva Duarte says,
构思绝妙的广播节目的开场白，节目名叫《士兵的革命将是阿根廷人民的革命》。很有BBC第四台风格的名字。名字真不错。于是我收听了这档节目。显然，这期节目于1944年8月14日在阿根廷广播电台播出。节目以戏剧化的方式演绎了阿根廷偏远地区的贫困实例。其中列举了肺结核发病率、文盲率和营养不良情况。节目中的女性角色由埃娃·杜阿尔特（Ava Duarte）饰演，她正是我们这个系列节目的主角，也就是更广为人知的艾薇塔（Evita），不久之后她将成为埃娃·佩隆（Ava Perron）。在这档播出的广播节目接近尾声时，她发表了讲话。埃娃·杜阿尔特说道：
the revolution was made for exploited workers. It was made because of the fraud of dishonest politicians and because the country was bankrupt of feeling at the verge of suicide. There was one man who could bring dignity to the notion of work, a soldier of the people who could feel the flame of social justice. It was he who decisively helped the people's revolution. Now the name of this man
这场革命是为受剥削的劳苦大众进行的。它的爆发是因为无良政客的欺诈，是因为国家失去了温情、濒临自禁的边缘。曾经有一位能够赋予劳动尊严的人，一位能感受到社会正义烈火的人民士兵。正是他，决定性地帮助了人民的革命。现在，这个人的名字
is not given, but Dominic, I think it's fairly clear who is being alluded to. And that person is Colonel Juan Domingo Perón, the most significant political figure in Argentina in 1944. That's right. And a person with whom, by the time Ava is voicing that, she is having an affair. And the relationship between Ava and Perón is at the heart of this extraordinary story. It is indeed, Tom. Hello, everybody. At the point when they do that, she does that broadcast, their relationship is about eight months old.
并没有被说出来，但多米尼克，我认为暗示的是谁已经相当清楚了。这个人就是胡安·多明戈·佩隆（Juan Domingo Perón）上校，1944年阿根廷政坛最重要的人物。没错。而且，当埃娃为这段话配音时，她已经和这个人坠入爱河了。埃娃和佩隆之间的关系正是这个非凡故事的核心。确实如此，汤姆。大家好。在他们开展合作、她进行那次广播的时候，他们的恋情大约才持续了八个月。
They had met at the beginning of 1944. Now, if you listened to the last episode, you will remember that she moved from the endless rural hinterland of the Pampa to Buenos Aires to seek her fortune, to make her career in radio and in show business. And then actually she hasn't done too badly because after a lot of struggle and poverty and kind of cast and couch misery, by the beginning of 1944, she is an established radio actress, isn't she, Tom? We were talking about her last
他们于1944年初相识。如果你听了上一期节目，你就会记得，她从潘帕斯草原一望无际的乡村腹地搬到了布宜诺斯艾利斯，去寻找她的发财梦，去在广播界和演艺圈闯荡一番事业。事实上，她干得还算不错，因为经过一番挣扎、贫困以及所谓的“沙发试镜”的痛苦之后，到1944年初，她已经成了一名颇具名气的广播女演员了，对吧，汤姆？我们上一次还在讨论她演的
time in all these soap operas. She is. And we were talking about how when she began, she was playing the part of housemaids and secretaries and so on. But this time she's starting to play queens she is indeed so she gets cast to play the part of various significant female figures from history so heroines of history it's called that's right there's a series and among them is elizabeth the first yeah catherine the great lady hamilton so uh nelson's lover wow Mrs. Chiang Kai-shek, so all the stars of history. But it's a sign that, you know, she's kind of made it, hasn't she? So at least in the terms of radio stars, she's become acting royalty. She has.
那些肥皂剧。是的。我们还聊过，她刚出道时演的都是女佣、秘书之类的小角色，但这次她开始演女王了。她确实演了女王。因此她被选中饰演历史上各个重要的女性人物，也就是所谓的历史上的女英雄，没错，这是一个系列，其中包括伊丽莎白一世，是的，叶卡捷琳娜大帝，汉密尔顿夫人——纳尔逊的情人，哇，蒋介石夫人，全都是历史上的大人物。但这表明，你知道，她算是成功了，对吧？至少在广播明星的领域里，她已经成了表演界的皇室成员。确实如此。
It's an interesting one, isn't it? Because she's playing heroines of history, these strong women. And of course, she's remembered herself as a strong woman. But as that reading that you did, the woman, lots of our listeners, particularly if they are women, will say, oh, how disappointing that actually that program, the woman is merely the handmaiden of the man, of Peron. And that sort of tension lies at the heart of Evita's story, that on the one hand, she is the personification of the strong woman, I suppose. But as we will see, everything for her is about Perón. Her entire political persona, as bizarre as it may sound,
这是一个很有趣的现象，不是吗？因为她扮演的是历史上的女英雄，这些坚强的女性。当然，她自己也被人们记住是一个坚强的女性。但正如你刚才朗读的那个广播片段——那个女人，我们的许多听众，尤其是女性听众，可能会觉得：真让人失望啊，原来那个节目里的“女人”不过是男人的附属品，是佩隆的婢女。这种矛盾心理正是艾薇塔故事的核心：一方面，她可以说是坚强女性的化身；但正如我们将要看到的，对她而言，一切都围绕着佩隆转。她整个的政治公众形象，听起来可能有些诡异，
is based on a kind of self-abnegation, being wrapped up with this army officer who becomes the most significant politician, arguably, in Argentina's history. To do the heroines of history, she actually had to get permission to do that. She had to go to see army officers. And the reason for that is that in the summer of 1943, there had been a military coup in Argentina. This is not something that had massively impinged on her, or there's no sense that she had cared about it, or that she was even particularly political. But there has been this reasonably bloodless military coup. Argentina at this point, I mean, is wealthy and successful, but is it a functioning democracy? Are coups two a penny?
是建立在一种自我牺牲的基础之上的，她把自己同这位后来成为阿根廷历史上最具分量的政治家的陆军军官紧紧捆绑在了一起。为了饰演历史上的女英雄，她实际上必须获得批准。她不得不去拜访陆军军官。原因在于，1943年夏天，阿根廷发生了一场军事政变。这件事并没有对她产生太大的影响，也没有迹象表明她曾在意过，或者她对政治有什么特别的兴趣。但这场相当温和的军事政变就这样发生了。此时的阿根廷，我是说，它既富有又成功，但它是一个运转良好的民主国家吗？政变是不是家常便饭？
Is this unusual? It's politics for a bit of a mess. You can basically take that as read at every given moment of this entire series, that it's politics are a bit chaotic and a bit of a mess. So there had been a radical president called Irigoyen in 1930 who'd been toppled. And then in the 1930s, they call it in Argentina, the infamous decade. I mean, actually, by the standards of the 1930s, Argentina is really not that infamous. Not bad. Or indeed the 70s in Argentina, I guess. Exactly. But they had a succession of very corrupt kind of oligarchic. There's a lot of talk about this, the oligarchy.
这很不寻常吗？这里的政治简直就是一团糟。你基本上可以把这当作整个系列节目的基本常识：这里的政治总是既混乱又一团糟。1930年，有一位名叫伊里戈延（Irigoyen）的激进派总统被推翻了。然后在20世纪30年代，阿根廷人称之为“臭名昭著的十年”。其实，以30年代的标准来看，阿根廷真算不上那么臭名昭著。还算过得去。或者说，相比阿根廷的70年代，我猜。一点没错。但当时他们经历了一连串非常腐败的寡头政治。人们经常谈论这个，即寡头集团。
And the oligarchy, the big conservative landowners. So they had run Argentine politics throughout the 1930s. And actually, people were getting a bit sick of them by the 1940s because they say, these people just sew everything up for their own interests. They're actually total puppets. Just hanging out at Harrods, playing polo, all that. Yeah, British capital. And there's a group of young military officers in 1943 who had said,
寡头集团，也就是那些拥有大片土地的保守派地主。他们在整个20世纪30年代一直把持着阿根廷政权。事实上到了40年代，人们开始对他们感到有点厌烦了，因为大家觉得，这些人为了自身的利益把一切都包揽了。他们其实就是彻头彻尾的傀儡。整天泡在哈罗德百货公司打马球，诸如此类。对，英国资本。1943年，有一群年轻的军官站出来说：
enough, Argentina can do better than these sort of people in tweed suits talking about the chukka and drinking port or whatever they're doing. Yeah, we're better than this. And they pointed out, you know, most of our economy is actually owned by British firms. All our railways are owned by the British. American companies own the whole automobile. This is wrong. Argentina should run its own companies.
够了，阿根廷完全可以比这群穿花呢西装、谈论马球（chukka）并喝着波特酒或者无论他们在干什么的人做得更好。是的，我们比这更强。他们指出，你知道，我们的大部分经济实际上都被英国公司掌控了。我们所有的铁路都归英国人所有。美国公司垄断了整个汽车行业。这是不对的。阿根廷应该经营自己的公司。
We're not just a province, basically, of the British Empire. And so they had swept away the existing government in 1943. And the big star of that group of officers is this guy, Juan Peron. So I know, Tom, you love that film, Evita. And in the film, he's played by Jonathan Price, who is a very distinguished actor. He's just not Juan Peron. I like Jonathan Price's hair in the film. It looks completely artificial. And I think that that is true to Juan Peron's tonsorial style. He's a big burly man, isn't he? You were comparing him to Dominic West.
我们基本上不只是大英帝国的一个省。因此，他们在1943年推翻了当时的政府。这群军官中最耀眼的明星就是这个人，胡安·佩隆。我知道，汤姆，你很喜欢那部电影《艾薇塔》。在电影中，他由乔纳森·普雷斯（Jonathan Price）饰演，他是一位非常杰出的演员。他只是长得不像胡安·佩隆。我挺喜欢电影里乔纳森·普雷斯的头发的。看起来完全是假的。我觉得这倒是挺符合胡安·佩隆的发型风格的。他是个身材魁梧的大块头，对吧？你曾把他比作多米尼克·韦斯特（Dominic West）。
And I think that's a really good shout. A big shout out to Dominic West, who listens to The Rest is History. Nice to have you with us. You should play Juan Perron if there is ever a Netflix drama about Perron. So Perron is much older than Ava. He was born in 1895. So he's almost 20 years older. In fact, he is 20 years older.
我觉得这个比方真的很贴切。向收听《历史的余烬》的多米尼克·韦斯特致敬。很高兴有你加入我们。如果未来网飞（Netflix）要拍一部关于佩隆的电视剧，你应该去演胡安·佩隆。所以佩隆比埃娃大得多。他出生于1895年。所以他比埃娃大将近20岁。事实上，他确实大她20岁。
He was the son of a guy who was like a tenant farmer, basically. He's born in Buenos Aires province in the middle of nowhere. His father goes off to Patagonia. Juan is sent off to school in Buenos Aires boarding school. He's a very sporty boy.
他的父亲基本上是个佃农。他出生在布宜诺斯艾利斯省一个鸟不拉屎的地方。他的父亲去了巴塔哥尼亚。胡安被送到布宜诺斯艾利斯的一所寄宿学校读书。他是个非常喜欢运动的男孩。
He's a big person. Except Dominic. Intriguingly, he's keen on kind of individual sports, but shockingly for an Argentine, he doesn't like football. He doesn't really like team sports team sports is that right and i don't know whether there's some kind of psychological cast can be read into that he's he's not a team player well do you know what he loves is fencing and of course oswald mosley is a champion fencer i mean that is a that is a film waiting to be written that The Oswald Mosley,
他是个身材高大的人。除了多米尼克之外。有趣的是，他热衷于个人运动，但令人震惊的是，作为一个阿根廷人，他居然不喜欢足球。他其实不太喜欢团队运动——团队运动，是这样吗？我不知道这其中是否能看出某种心理特征。他不是一个团队合作者。不过你知道他喜欢什么吗？他喜欢击剑，当然，奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利（Oswald Mosley）就是个击剑冠军。我的意思是，这简直是一个等待被搬上银幕的故事：奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利
Juan Perón fencing contest. But Dominic, I think that Perón, just to stick up for him, is a much more attractive figure than Mosley. Yeah. He's kind of fun, isn't he? He's amusing.
和胡安·佩隆的击剑对决。不过多米尼克，我觉得，为佩隆说句公道话，他比莫斯利要迷人得多。是的。他挺有意思的，不是吗？他很幽默。
People like him in a way that Mosley is kind of more fascist leader in waiting. And Perón is not really a fascist. Perón is not a cad in the way that Mosley is good, although Perón is guilty later a fascist. Peron is not a cad in the way that Moses get, although Peron is guilty later on of some quite dubious behavior. Peron is not a kind of out and out bounder. So from the point when he goes into the military academy, everybody says to Peron,
人们喜欢他，而莫斯利则更像是一个蓄势待发的法西斯头子。佩隆其实并不是那种像莫斯利那样让人讨厌的无赖，尽管佩隆后来确实有一些相当可疑的行为。佩隆不是那种彻头彻尾的恶棍。所以从他进入军事学院的那天起，每个人都对佩隆说：
he's a really big man. He's a big man in the barracks. He's popular with the other guys, like he's more than six feet tall. As you said, Tom, he's handsome and he's kind of burly, but he's a good laugh. He's very charming. He's easygoing. You know, he's not prickly. He's not ridiculously proud. He's not particularly aggressive. He's actually good company. He doesn't seem to take himself seriously, which again is kind of massive contrast with Mosley. And I suppose generally with kind of fascist dictators in this period, he is someone who can almost laugh at himself, comparing him to Eva, who never laughs at herself. I mean, that is a real point of contrast. It is. It is.
他真的是个大块头。他在军营里是个大人物。他很受其他伙伴的欢迎，他的身高超过六英尺。正如你所说的，汤姆，他很英俊，身材魁梧，但他很爱笑。他非常迷人。他随和。你知道，他并不尖锐。他没有荒谬的傲慢。他也不是特别好斗。他其实是个很好的伙伴。他似乎并不把自己看得太重，这再次与莫斯利形成了巨大的反差。我想，这也普遍区别于这一时期的法西斯独裁者：他是一个几乎能自嘲的人。相比之下，埃娃从不自嘲。我的意思是，这真是一个鲜明的对比。确实如此。
So his first wife is totally unlike Eva Peron. She's a schoolteacher called Aurelia Tizon. They got married in 1929. She died of uterine cancer in 1938. And he is supposedly very upset. There is actually a story that he was at the barracks with the guys, and they're just gossiping about girls. They said, oh, you're very quiet.
所以他的第一任妻子与埃娃·佩隆截然不同。她是一位名叫奥雷利亚·蒂宗（Aurelia Tizon）的女教师。他们于1929年结婚。她于1938年死于子宫癌。据说他为此非常难过。事实上还有一个故事说，当时他和伙伴们在军营里，大家正闲聊着女孩的话题。他们说：“哦，你怎么这么安静？”
And he said, actually, I've only ever been with my wife. So although he's a bit of a matinee idol, I don't think he's a complete player in the sense that you might expect him to be. I mean, he never really talks about his first wife. So the only public comment he ever made on her was made in an interview he gave in 1970. And he said that she was a very nice girl, a concert guitarist. She played very well.
他说：“其实，我这辈子只和我的妻子在一起过。”所以，尽管他有点像大众情人，但我觉得他并不像你想象的那样是个花花公子。我的意思是，他从来不怎么谈论他的第一任妻子。因此，他唯一一次在公开场合对她做出评价，是在1970年的一次采访中。他说她是个非常好的女孩，是一位古典吉他手，琴艺精湛。
Unfortunately, she died young. I mean, not the most emotional testimony. Not the most effusive, no. Given they were married for almost 10 years, Tom. And as you say, she dies of uterine cancer. Yeah. And that is something for the listener to bear in mind. Yeah. So he's rising through the ranks of the military in the 1930s. I mean, they're not fighting anybody, obviously. So actually, they just spend their time training. And he's a history professor at the Military Academy. I'm just wondering about this, the fact that the Argentine's military are not fighting.
不幸的是，她英年早逝。我的意思是，这可不是什么充满情感的表白。也不是最热情洋溢的，确实不是。考虑到他们结婚将近十年了，汤姆。正如你所说，她死于子宫癌。是的。这是听众需要记住的一点。是的。因此，他在20世纪30年代的军队中步步高升。我的意思是，显然他们没有跟任何人打仗。所以实际上，他们只是把时间花在训练上。他是军事学院的一门历史教授。我只是在想这件事，阿根廷军队没有参与实战，
Does this give a sense of perhaps that they are playing at being soldiers? You know, war is breaking out in Europe at this point. Argentina is standing aloof from it. The emphasis on braid and medals and large peak caps and everything that becomes such a feature of the Argentine military. Do you think that in a way, just as Ava is playing at being a queen, Peron is kind of playing at being a colonel? Maybe a tiny bit, Tom. Argentine military listeners will be very offended by this bit of the conversation.
这是否会让人觉得他们其实是在过家家、假装当士兵呢？你知道，当时欧洲正爆发战争。阿根廷却置身事外。他们对军服饰带、勋章、大檐帽以及所有后来成为阿根廷军队标志性特征的事物有着极大的偏爱。你是否认为，某种程度上，正如埃娃在扮演女王一样，佩隆其实也在扮演上校？也许有一点点，汤姆。阿根廷军队的听众听到这段对话可能会感到非常被冒犯。
Yeah, but to not be fighting at a time when all the world is at war. I mean, it's quite something, isn't it? I think it's fair to say Juan Peron must have never fired a shot in anger and probably never really saw a shot fired in anger in his entire life. And that was true of a lot of Argentine officers of his generation. There is fighting in South America. So there's a war between Bolivia and Paraguay called the Chaco War, a horrible war in the 1930s, but Argentina is not involved. They go and they tour Europe and things, and they observe other armies. But you're right. There is a slight element of the Gilbert and Sullivan maybe about all this. The training that the Argentine military get is very German, isn't it?
是的，但在全世界都在打仗的时候却没有参战。我的意思是，这挺不寻常的，不是吗？我想可以公平地说，胡安·佩隆一生中绝未在愤怒中开过一枪，可能在他的整个一生中也从未真正见过愤怒的枪声。阿根廷他那一代的许多军官都是如此。南美洲其实是有战争的。玻利维亚和巴拉圭之间曾发生过一场名为查科战争的惨烈战争，那是20世纪30年代的一场可怕战争，但阿根廷没有卷入其中。他们去欧洲等地游历，观察其他军队。不过你说得对。这一切确实带有那么一点点吉尔伯特与沙利文（Gilbert and Sullivan）喜歌剧的色彩。阿根廷军队受到的训练非常德国化，不是吗？
It's very German. He wrote a book about the Eastern Front in the Great War, so Germans versus Russians. He wrote a book about the Russo-Japanese War. He teaches the campaigns of the Franco-Prussian War, the campaigns of the First world war and so on but um kind of emotionally he seems to dislike violence he's not a man who relishes it I think that's absolutely right again that's not generally a feature of fascists is it no not at all so this
非常德国化。他写过一本关于大战中东线战事——也就是德国对阵俄国的书。他写过一本关于日俄战争的书。他教授法普战争的战役、第一次世界大战的战役等等，但是……从情感上讲，他似乎很厌恶暴力，他不是一个享受暴力的人。我认为这绝对没错。同样，这通常也不是法西斯的特征，对吧？一点也不。所以
question about Peron and fascism I mean we might as well just get into that right away because in 1939 he is sent as a military attaché to Italy. He specializes in Alpine troops. He's going to ski troopers. That's be useful on the pamper. Yeah. Well, there are, you know, he goes off to Mendoza, where there is some skiing. Yeah, fair enough.
关于佩隆和法西斯主义的这个问题，我的意思是，我们不妨马上切入正题，因为在1939年，他被派往意大利担任武官。他专攻高山部队。他要去滑雪骑兵队。这在潘帕斯草原上可派不上用场。嗯，当然，他们去门多萨（Mendoza）考察，那里有一些滑雪场。是的，倒也是。
Because, of course, if they were ever to fight Chile, they would have to do it in the Andes. You were totally right when you said about Germany. The Argentine army, it was modeled on the German army. Spikes on helmets, goose stepping, all that. Spikes on helmets, they use German manuals, all of that kind of thing. Peron goes to Germany when he's in Europe and he sees Hitler's Germany and he says, this is absolutely brilliant. He describes it as an enormous piece of machinery functioning with marvelous perfection where not even the smallest piece was missing. His biographer Joseph Page wrote a great book about Peron, said of him, he clearly found nothing at all to object to in Nazi Germany or fascist Italy.
因为当然了，如果他们要跟智利打仗，就必须在安第斯山脉进行。你关于德国的说法完全正确。阿根廷军队就是以德国军队为蓝本建立的。头盔上的尖顶、鹅步，所有这些。头盔上的尖顶，他们使用德国的军事手册，诸如此类的事情。佩隆在欧洲期间曾访问德国，他看到了希特勒的德国，并说：这真是太棒了。他将其形容为“一台以惊人完美度运转的庞大机器，甚至连最小的零件都没有缺失”。他的传记作家约瑟夫·佩奇（Joseph Page）写过一本关于佩隆的优秀著作，其中提到他：“他显然在纳粹德国或法西斯意大利找不到任何可反对的地方。”
He talks about them afterwards or at the time. He says, oh, brilliant. Trains run on time. Everything is very ordered. Love it. He does, however, visit Spain in the aftermath of the civil war. And he's appalled by what he sees there. So again, I think it's that when he's visiting Germany and Italy, the violence inherent in the fascist regimes there are not as
他后来或在当时谈到这些时说：哦，太棒了。火车准点运行。一切都井井有条。真喜欢。不过，他确实在内战结束后访问了西班牙。他对在那里看到的一切感到震惊。所以同样，我认为当他访问德国和意大利时，那里法西斯政权固有的暴力并不像在西班牙那样明显，在西班牙，整座整座的城市都成了一片废墟。因此，正如我们在这个系列节目后面将看到的，他和佛朗哥（Franco）之间有一种略显微妙的关系。确实如此。是的，完全正确。纳粹的反犹太主义，他们意识形态上的种种极端行径，我认为他对此感到莫名其妙。并且有一些证据表明，有一两次犹太人的话题被提及。像许多人一样，他会说类似“犹太人太多了”这样的话，或者，你知道的，他会沉溺于那种温和的酒吧反犹言论。但这并不像——比如佛朗哥就非常反犹。嗯，实际上——后来当他掌权时，
obvious as they are in Spain, where entire cities are in ruins. And so he has a kind of prickly relationship with Franco, as we will see later in this series. He does indeed. Yeah, absolutely right. So the sort of the anti-Semitism of the Nazis, their sort of ideological excesses, he's just baffled, I think, by that. And there's some evidence that once or twice the subject of Jews came up. And like a lot of people, he would sort of say, oh, there are too many Jews or, you know, he'd indulge in kind of mild saloon bar antisemitism. But it's not like, so Franco, for example, was very antisemitic. Well, he actually, I mean, later when he's in power,
他阻止追随者发起反犹太措施。他确实这样做了。他实际上仰慕的人是墨索里尼。他后来声称——他编造了一个故事，说自己曾与墨索里尼握手。因为这种事不是大多数人会凭空捏造的。但他无疑认为墨索里尼是一个伟大的人物。因此，当墨索里尼在二战临近结束时被捕，并因德国伞兵一次极其大胆的突袭而获救时，佩隆认为这太棒了。他为此举杯庆祝。他当时在一次晚宴上说：哦，为营救这位了不起的同仁墨索里尼干杯。他喜欢墨索里尼及其意大利的地方，以及我认为对他产生重大影响的是：
he discourages his followers from launching antisemitic measures. He does indeed. The person he looks up to actually is Mussolini. He claimed later on he invented a story that he had shaken Mussolini's hand. Because that's not the kind of thing that most people would be making up. But he undoubtedly thinks Mussolini is a very great man. So when Mussolini was held prisoner towards the end of the Second World War, and he's famously rescued by German paratroopers in this very sort of daring raid, Perron thought this was brilliant. And he had a toast. He was at a dinner and he said, oh, toast to the rescue of this tremendous fellow Mussolini. And what he likes about Mussolini and Mussolini's Italy, and what I think make a big impact on him,
首先，他认为那是一个有机统一的社会，资本、大企业和劳工——也就是工人们——都团结在领袖（duce）的身后。带有浓厚的法团主义色彩。法团主义，完全正确。难道这不美妙吗？社会就该是这个样子。善良的人们走到一起，为了共同的利益而努力。是的，团结在真正关心人民的单一领袖身后。
first of all, he thinks it's a kind of organic community in which capital, big business, and labor, the workers, are united behind the duche. Kind of corporatist. Corporatist, exactly. And isn't that wonderful? That's how society should be. Good people getting together, working in the common good. Yeah, behind the single leader who really cares about his people.
不过他也确实喜欢旗帜和那种趾高气扬的派头，不是吗？没错。我认为，庇隆主义的核心更多的是一种风格而非实质。这种风格就是仪式、奇观、集会、旗帜，以及一种疯狂而过度的伤感主义。事实上，这种政治很有趣。比起在一个昏暗的房间里讨论诸如收入政策之类的事，它要有意思得多。这种伤感主义和夸张的情感基调，显然，如果让男女双性作为政权的公开门面，效果会更好。
But he does also like the flags and the swagger, doesn't he? Well, that's it. At the heart of Peronism, I think, is a style rather than substance. And the style is ritual, spectacle, rallies, flags, and a kind of madly excessive sentimentality. And actually, that kind of politics is fun. It is more fun than talking about, you know, incomes policies in this kind of darkened room. And the sentimentality of it and the kind of histrionic emotional pitch is obviously one that works better if you have people of both sexes
当然是这样。所以一个男人和一个女人，完美。还有什么比一对夫妇共同出面更好的呢，汤姆？那么，这对于佩隆来说可能是真的吗，我们觉得？我认为是有可能的。他在二战中期回到阿根廷。他有时会暴躁，但随后又会平静下来并放声大笑。他给人一种充满幽默感、凡事不那么较真的印象。OSS（中央情报局的前身）对他的评价是：虽然不是一个有文化的人，但个性随和，具备决策能力以及实施暴力的能力。
as the public front of the regime. Of course it is. So a man and a woman, perfect. What could be better than a couple doing it, Tom? So is that something that might be possible for Perron, do we think? I think it is possible. He comes back to Argentina in the middle of the Second World War. And he is violent, but then he calms himself and he laughs loudly. He gives the impression of a permanent sense of humour and gives the feeling he doesn't take things too seriously. And the OSS, which is an ancestor of the CIA, very similar. Not a cultured person, but possessed of an affable personality, decision-making ability and a capacity for violence.
事实上，OSS在1943年就曾断言：他终有一天会成为阿根廷总统，而且他会通过一种受控的民主来实现这一点，这会给他披上一层合法的外衣，而实际上他将成为一个独裁者、威权统治者。说实话，我觉得还有比这更糟糕的独裁者。确实有。我的意思是，我并不认为《历史的余烬》的听众通常会是20世纪独裁者的粉丝。没有。但如果非得选一个的话，可能他会是那个人。
And actually, the OSS in 1943 said, he will one day be the president of Argentina and he will do it with a kind of managed democracy that would give him the appearance of legality, whereas he will actually be the autocrat, the authoritarian. I think there are worse kinds of dictators to have, to be honest. There are. I mean, I don't think the rest of history is generally a fan of 20th century dictators. No. But if you had to choose one, probably he'd be the one.
你觉得呢？这是一个显而易见的问题。这可是通往被取消资格（cancellation）的道路啊，汤姆。你最喜欢的独裁者是谁？如你所知，我有一个印有铁托头像的抱枕。我还有铁托的食谱。所以此时此刻，我得为铁托投上一票。
Do you think? I mean, it's an obvious question. This is the road to cancellation, Tom. Who's your favorite dictator? So as you know, I have a cushion with Tito's face on it. And I also have Tito's cookbook. So I've got to put a bid in for Tito at this point.
但我认为他们是一丘之貉。那种慈祥、魁梧的……身上带着一丝里根式的特质。以及他那种……我觉得还得戴墨镜。你必须得戴墨镜。我挺喜欢男人戴墨镜的。
But I think they're cut from a similar cloth. The avuncular, burly... Faintly Reagan-esque quality to him. And his kind of... I think dark glasses. You've got to have dark glasses. I like that in a man.
还有对服饰饰带的执着。哦，他是真的很爱他的饰带。我的意思是，我想关于他的另一点是，他其实并不是一个有什么坚定信念的人，对吧？不太算。
And an obsession with braid. Oh, he loved his braid. Well, I mean, I suppose the other thing about him, he's not really a man of conviction, is he? Not especially.
除了他应该掌权这个信念之外。正如你所说，一切都关乎氛围之类的，你能感受到他想要什么的某种情感趋向，而政策的具体细节实际上倒显得不那么重要了。他把各种不同的项目拼凑在一起。所以他有句著名的格言，不是吗：唯一的真理就是现实。这对于一个政客来说是一句非常有用的格言。是的。不难理解为什么后来会出现左翼庇隆主义者和右翼庇隆主义者。而他们的政治立场却截然相反。
Beyond the conviction that he should be in power. And as you saying you know it's all about the vibe and stuff you get the kind of the emotional sense of what he wants and then the details of the policy is actually kind of less relevant he's kind of stitching together all kinds of different programs so he had this famous aphorism doesn't The only truth is reality. And that's a very useful aphorism for a politician to have. Yeah. No, it's why later on you get left-wing Peronists and right-wing Peronists. And they are literally at the opposite end of the political spectrum.
但他们都是庇隆主义者。这到底意味着什么？我的意思是，这才是令人感到不可思议的地方。正如埃娃的传记作家尼古拉斯·弗雷泽（Nicholas Fraser）和玛丽萨·纳瓦罗（Marisa Navarro）所说，世上并没有一个唯一的佩隆，只有一连串不同的佩隆。我觉得可以公正地说，他其实也像埃娃一样在扮演一个角色。而且他即兴发挥的能力也极强。确实如此。
But they're both Peronists. And what does that even mean? I mean, this is the baffling thing. As Ava's biographers, Nicholas Fraser and Marisa Navarro say, there was no one Peron. There were just a series of Perons. He too is playing a part like Ava is, I think it's fair to say. And he's brilliant at improvising as well. He is.
因此他可以根据出现的机遇来改变自己的个性和形象。同样，这对于解释他如何利用与埃娃的婚姻将至关重要。完全正确。他在政治上简直太厉害、太老练了。所以1943年后，他是陆军部的二号人物，但基本上就是那个举足轻重的大人物。他主动索要并得到了劳工部，这是一个听起来极其缺乏光彩的部门，但他很聪明。这不是一个能显摆军服饰带的部门，对吧？对，但他知道阿根廷的工会运动落后于欧洲。因此只有一小部分劳动力加入了工会。
So he can change his personality, his image, depending on the opportunities that emerge. And again, this will be crucial in explaining the uses that he puts his marriage to Ava to. Exactly. He's just really, really good at politics. So after 1943, he was the number two in the war ministry, but basically the big man. And he asked for and got the Department of Labour, which is kind of an incredibly unglamorous thing to ask for, but he is smart. It's not a braid-friendly ministry, is it? No, but he knows that Argentina's trade union movement is behind those in Europe. So only a small proportion of the workforce are unionized.
而佩隆精明地算计着，像埃娃·杜阿尔特这样在过去十年左右搬到布宜诺斯艾利斯、没有任何代表权、感到备受压迫的人。如果我能成为站在他们这边的人，如果我能为他们建立工会、去见领袖们并为他们争取福利等等，他们就会爱戴我。而这正是他所做的。事实上，智利记者在1943年就曾说过：如果他做到了这一点，如果他成功了，他将成为阿根廷共和国的强人、伟大的考迪罗（caudillo）。而且谁知道能持续多久呢？你知道，他正在工人阶级中建立自己的权力基础。
And Perón calculates people like, actually, Eva Duarte, who have moved to Buenos Aires in the last decade or so, who don't have any representation, who feel very downtrodden. If I can be the person on their side, if I could found unions for them and get to meet the leaders and give them benefits and stuff, they will love me. And that's what he does. And actually, Chilean journalists said in 1943, you know, if he does this, if he pulls this off, he will be the strongman, the great caudillo of the Argentine Republic. And who knows for how long? You know, he is building up this power base among the working classes.
他非常像古罗马共和国晚期政治中的克洛狄乌斯（Clodius）。是这样吗？就是那个在罗马设立粮食救济金并从原本只有混乱无序的地方组建准军事组织的保民官。所以这其中也许有一点点那种色彩。罗马共和国的“无衫汉”（Descamisados）。正是如此。所以正如你所说，佩隆是一个伟大的即兴表演者，一个巨大的机会主义者。1944年1月，圣胡安市（San Juan）发生了一场可怕的地震，至少导致10万人死亡。佩隆对政府中的其他人说：这事我来，你知道，我来处理。再次展现了他出色的即兴能力，你知道，绝不让
He's very like Clodius in the politics of the late Roman Republic. Is that so? The tribune who establishes the bread dole in Rome and he fashions paramilitaries out of where previously there had been nothing but kind of inchoate chaos. So there's maybe a faint element of that perhaps. The Descamisados of the Roman Republic. Exactly so. So Peron, as you said, he's a great improviser, a great opportunist. In January 1944, there's a terrible earthquake in the city of San Juan, kills at least 10,000 people. And Peron says to the other people in the government, I've got this, you know, I will handle this. Again, the great improviser, you know, not letting
灾难白白浪费。佩隆全力投入到救援工作中，送去了衣服、金钱以及所有这些，但他想出了一个绝妙的计策，这个计策能把所有的知名演员、女演员和歌手都吸引过来。周六那天，他们会与军政府的人一起穿过布宜诺斯艾利斯市中心。每个人都会拿着一个募捐箱。我的意思是，想象一下那个场景，所有这些演员和人们都在捐款，我的意思是，这太棒了。如果这种事在伦敦发生，那该是多么惊人的景象啊。但这就是为什么埃娃和佩隆是西区音乐剧的完美题材。是的。我的意思是，西区音乐剧里的那些明星们会走出来做这种事情。
a disaster go to waste. And Peron is all over the relief efforts and he's sending out clothes and money and all this, but he's got a brilliant wheeze and his wheezes will get all the big actors and actresses and singers and stuff. On a Saturday, they will go through the center of Buenos Aires with people from the military government. Each one will have a money box. I mean, imagine the scene, all these actors and people giving, I mean, that's brilliant. If that happened in London, what an amazing thing that would be. But this is why Ava and Perron are such perfect subjects for a kind of West End musical. Yeah. I mean, the kind of, you know, the stars in West End musicals would go out and do this kind of thing.
你知道，他们会佩戴丝带。本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇（Benedict Cumberbatch），我能想象他去做这件事。对，绝对的。这种结合太绝了。当时的埃娃·杜阿尔特无疑也参与其中。她会喜欢这种事情的。她所有的朋友都去了。
You know, they'd wear ribbons. Benedict Cumberbatch, I can see him doing it. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. The nexus is so brilliant. Ava Duarte, as she then was, undoubtedly went to this. She'd love this kind of thing. All her friends are going.
她绝对去了。佩隆后来声称，这就是他们初次相遇的时候。大多数人认为这根本不对。她当时根本不可能给他留下深刻印象。但在那天晚上，
She undoubtedly went. Peron said later, this is when they first met. Most people think that's not right at all. She would not have made an impression on him. But that evening,
有一个名为“月神公园”（Luna Park）的大型体育竞技场。那是马拉多纳举办婚礼喜宴的地方。也是在我们录制这期节目的当周，哈维尔·米莱（Javier Millay）举行新书发布会的地方，
there's a big sports arena called the Luna Park. It's where Maradona had his wedding reception. And it's where, in the week that we're recording this, Javier Millay had a book launch
他在那里和他的摇滚乐队一起唱歌，并大肆抨击共产主义。所以，场面非常盛大。但他没有跟……不，确实没有。无论如何，总之在月神公园，他们举办了一场盛大的晚会。佩隆去了。
where he sang with his rock band and ranted about communism. So, great scenes. But he didn't juggle with... No, exactly. Anyway, so at the Luna Park, they have a big gala. Peron goes.
埃娃和一个朋友也去了。她盛装打扮。很显然，她看上了他。他比她大得多，但不幸的是，他身上长了皮疹。你注意到这个了吗？不，我漏掉了。那是一种很可怕的皮疹。
Ava goes with a friend of hers. She's all dressed up. She clearly has her eye on him. He is much older, but he unfortunately has a rash. Do you see this? No, I missed that. It's a terrible rash. So he has psoriasis. So is much older, but he unfortunately has a rash. Do you see this? No, I've missed that. It's a terrible rash.
所以他有银屑病（牛皮癣）。因此他总是涂抹大量的乳霜和化妆品来掩盖皮疹。实际上，这意味着他在照片里显得格外光彩照人，
So he has psoriasis. So he always wears a lot of cream and makeup to hide the rash. And actually, what that means is he photographs brilliantly because he's all shiny
因为他油光发亮的或者别的什么原因，我不知道是因为他的皮疹还是什么。总之，他看起来棒极了。不管有没有皮疹。这是音乐剧中非常著名的一个片段，佩隆上校和埃娃·杜阿尔特
or something. I don't know what it is because of his rash. Anyway, he looks brilliant. Rash or no rash. This is a famous bit in the musical where Colonel Perron ever do art and
两人合唱道：“久仰大名。”他其实不太可能听说过她。好吧，这正是我要问的：他听说过她吗？她当时真的那么有名吗？我觉得可能性极低。你听说过任何广播剧女演员吗？没有。但如果我遇到《阿契尔一家》（The Archers）里的演员，我大概能认出他们的声音。是菲丽希缇·琼斯（Felicity Jones）吗？她演过《星球大G传：侠盗一号》。在我看来最好的星战电影。她演过《阿契尔一家》。好吧，你看。
then they both sing i've heard so much about you and it's off he's unlikely to have heard anything about her well this is what i wanted to ask would he have heard of her is she that famous by this point i think highly unlikely have you heard of any radio actresses no but if i met someone from the archers i'd probably recognize their voice. Felicity Jones, is it? Who was in Star Wars film Rogue One. The best Star Wars film, in my view. She was in The Archers. Well, there you go.
她就是在剧中陷入和格伦迪家族（Grundys）三角恋的那个人。我从来没听说过她。好吧，她很有名，汤姆。她是一位获得过奥斯卡提名的女演员。我从来没听说过她。我们在之前的节目里讨论过她上过哪所学校……是吗？当然讨论过！
She was the person who was in like a love triangle with the Grundys. I've never heard of her. Well, she's very famous, Tom. She's an Oscar nominated actress. I've never heard of her. We talked about her schooled on a previous... Did we? Of course we did.
我们在一期播客里讨论过她的私立学校。非常经典的《历史的余烬》。如果她在某次晚会上遇到了未来的英国独裁者，那会……总之，听着，这话题扯远了。这完全是一个糟糕的题外话。无论如何，他们相遇了，埃娃基本上主动占据了主导地位。而且，看过这部音乐剧的人都知道，佩隆当时已经有一个女朋友了，不是吗？佩隆和一个同居的人住在一起，他把她介绍给所有人——这在佩隆身上可不是什么好兆头，
We talked about her private school on a previous podcast. Very restless history. If she'd met the future dictator of Britain at a gala, that would... Anyway, listen, this is spiralling off. It's a terrible tangent. Anyway, they meet and Ava is basically, she is the one who is taking the lead. And again, people who've watched the musical will know that Perronron already has a girlfriend doesn't he perron is living with somebody who he introduces to everybody this is a bad sign with perron and
而且在这一系列的最后几集里情况会变得更糟。更有趣的是，他叫她“食人鱼”，不是吗？是的，目前还不清楚这是因为她太能吃，还是因为她有点地包天。她有覆咬合。所以佩隆有了这个女孩。她才17岁。她是来自门多萨的一个十几岁女孩，佩隆曾在那里教授山地战。她大概叫玛丽亚·伊内斯（Maria Ines），因为报纸人物简介曾说他有个叫玛丽亚·伊内斯的女儿。不幸的是，我觉得她只是一个极其不合时宜的
actually it will get worse in the final episodes of the series and also brilliantly she's called he calls he calls her the piranha doesn't he yeah and it's unclear whether that's because she eats so much or because she has a kind of overhanging lip. She has an overbite. So Peron has got this girl. She's 17 years old. She's a teenager from Mendoza where he had been teaching mountain warfare. And she's probably called Maria Ines because newspaper profiles said he has a daughter called Maria Ines. Unfortunately, I think she's just an extremely and inappropriately
年轻女友。当埃娃发现“食人鱼”正盘踞在那里时，她毫不迟疑地——是的，把她所有的行李都扔了出去。她实际上雇了一辆卡车，去把“食人鱼”的所有物品都拿走，装进卡车里，然后说：“你被炒了，回门多萨去吧。”这就是结局。不幸的是，“食人鱼”在辛苦工作了一天后回到家里（你知道的，去跟工会领袖们谈话了），结果发现“食人鱼”已经消失了。有传言说埃娃实际上买了一些自己的东西，并开始拆包搬进公寓里。我觉得这可能被夸大了，但我觉得——这其实挺有意思的，不是吗？因为它后来成了一个反庇隆主义者的攻击把柄。确实如此。
young girlfriend and when ava finds out that the piranha is in situ she wastes no time at all yeah chucks all her luggage out she actually hires a truck goes and gets all the piranhas possessions puts them in the truck and says you're out get back to mendoza so that is the end unfortunately piranha gets home after a hard day at the office you know talking to union leaders the piranha has vanished the story is that Ava had actually bought some of her own stuff and started unpacking like moving into the apartment I think that's probably exaggerated but I think I mean it's kind of interesting isn't it because it will become a kind of anti-peronist jibe. It is. That Ava wears the trousers, that Peron is a bit of a wimp in the relationship,
说埃娃是一家之主，说佩隆在感情中有点软弱，
that he does what she says. And you can see how, you know, that's a kind of classic misogynist angle to take. But it does seem to correspond to traits within their two personalities, that it's not that Peron is kind of submissive in any way. It's just that he is cooler, calmer, in a way more calculating. I think that's exactly exactly it and ava is just very impetuous and i guess that that is what will make them such
他总是听她的。你能看出，这是一种典型的厌女视角。但这确实似乎符合他们两个人性格中的某些特质：并不是说佩隆在任何方面逆来顺受，而是他更冷静、更沉着，某种程度上也更精于算计。我认为完全是这样。埃娃只是非常冲动，我想正是这一点让他们成为了
a good combination because in a way perron can use ava to kind of test things out before he you know he takes the step anyway they meet and basically they shack up and they're together for the rest of Ava's life, right? Yeah, that's exactly it. They make their first appearance together. It's just a few days afterwards, the 3rd of February. They're seen together for the first time at a broadcast. He goes and inspects the equipment and he speaks to all the actors. And from that point, as you say, they are a couple.
如此完美的组合。因为在某种程度上，佩隆可以利用埃娃来试探某些事情，然后再采取行动。无论如何，他们相遇了，基本上就同居了，并且在埃娃的余生中一直在一起，对吧？是的，完全如此。他们首次公开亮相是在那之后的几天，也就是2月3日。他们第一次一同出现在一场广播节目中。他去视察设备并与所有演员交谈。正如你所说，从那一刻起，他们正式成了一对伴侣。
Some of his colleagues, even then, then in those first weeks think this is awful she is totally the wrong person she's too common she's you know working class she is brash she is difficult you know they say all those things that actually are probably a lot of listeners will say oh god they're the things that men always say you know about somebody but you know perron's response to this quite witty go on what do they want me to do? Go out with an actor. Very good. Brilliant, brilliant advance. And I think on that Perronist witticism, we should take a break. And when we come back, Dominic, let's have a look. So the famous line in the musical is, I'd be surprisingly good for you. We could find out, is Ava surprisingly good for Perron? And indeed, is Perron good for Ava? We'll be back after the break.
他的一些同僚，甚至在当时、在那最初的几周里，都认为这太糟糕了。她完全是个错误的人选，她太低俗了，她是工人阶级的，她太鲁莽了，她很难对付。他们说了所有那些——其实很多听众会说：天哪，这些就是男人对某个人时总是会说的话。但佩隆对此的回应相当机智。接着说，他们希望我怎么做？和一个演员交往。非常妙。精彩绝伦的机智回应。我想，伴随着佩隆式的俏皮话，我们该休息一下了。当我们回来时，多米尼克，让我们来看看。音乐剧中那句著名的台词是：“我会对你出奇地好。”我们可以拭目以待：埃娃对佩隆来说真的会出奇地好吗？而佩隆对埃娃来说真的好吗？我们休息一下，马上回来。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Ava has met Peron. The great meeting, kind of the key meeting really in 20th century Argentine history, you might argue. Do you think it would that be?
如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并抢先获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。埃娃已经遇到了佩隆。这场伟大的相遇，可以说是20世纪阿根廷历史上的关键相遇。你认为可以这么说吗？
Lenin and McCartney meeting, the Walton Church fate of Argentine history. Yes. So you said how there are certainly his army colleagues are not happy about Ava. He sticks with her. Presumably he's very attracted to her. But later he says that he responds to a sense of goodness in Ava. So he said, I realized that I was faced with an extraordinary person. I was not attracted by the beautiful woman, but by the good woman. Of course, she incorporated the two extremes, beauty and goodness. Now, when he says that, and no reason to doubt it, I mean, he was devoted to Ava, it seems.
列宁和麦卡特尼的相遇，也就是阿根廷历史上的沃尔顿教堂命运时刻。是的。所以你提到他的军队同僚们当然对埃娃很不满意。但他依然坚持和她在一起。可以推测他被她深深吸引了。但后来他说，他在埃娃身上感受到了一种善良的品质。所以他说：“我意识到我面对的是一个非凡的人。吸引我的不是这个美丽的女人，而是这个善良的女人。当然，她集这两种极端——美丽与善良于一身。”现在，当他说这话时——而且我们没有理由怀疑他，因为他似乎对埃娃一往情深——
Is he talking solely as someone who's in love with a woman, or is he speaking as a politician who thinks that he has picked up an asset? Maybe both? No, I don't think both, actually. I don't think he views her as an asset at this point. I think in the first year and a half or so of their life together, my sense from what I have read is that she is simply to him his mistress. Because she kind of hangs around in his bedroom wearing his pyjamas, doesn't he?
他仅仅是以一个爱恋着女人的男人的身份在说话，还是作为一个认为自己捡到了一笔政治资产的政客在发言？也许两者皆有？不，我不认为两者皆有。我不认为他此时将她视为一种资产。根据我的阅读，在他们共同生活的头一年半左右的时间里，我的感觉是，她对她而言仅仅是他的情妇。因为她只是穿着他的睡衣在他的卧室里晃来晃去，不是吗？
She does. There's a guy called General Farrell who becomes the new president in February. So just a month after they've met, he is Peron's boss. Peron takes over his old job at the war ministry. So Peron is now running the war ministry and the labor ministry. Peron is like the power behind the throne. He's having meetings all the time with other officers, with union leaders, with bigwigs and stuff in his apartment. She is present, but she's literally making the coffee. She says nothing by and large. And sometimes people say to Peron's intimates, you know, who's the girl? Who's the floozy kind of thing? And actually the quote is, she is one of those tiresome girls who screw all over the place in the hope that someone will give them a part. She's just a girlfriend. That's all she is. And she continues
是的，她去了。2月时有个叫法雷尔的将军成了新总统。所以在他们见面仅一个月后，他就成了庇隆的上司。庇隆接替了他原来在战争部的职位。所以庇隆现在同时掌管着战争部和劳工部。庇隆就像是权力的幕后操纵者。他一直在公寓里与其他军官、工会领袖、大人物等开会。她也在场，但她实际上只是在煮咖啡。总的来说她一言不发。有时庇隆的亲信会问，这女孩是谁？这是个什么样的风骚女人？实际上当时的原话是，她就是那种到处和人上床、希望别人能给她个角色的讨厌女孩。她只是个女朋友。她就这点身份。而她还在继续
with her show business career. So you said she's playing the Empress Alexandra. She's playing Queen Elizabeth I. Because she's the big man's girl. That helps with her career. Yeah. She sees herself as a Hollywood film star. And I think she wants to affect that kind of image. So it's the poor man's JFK and Marilyn. Yeah. In a way. There's no sense at this point that she is a particularly political animal or that he sees her in that light. So she says of him that he was fabulous, strong and tender at the same time, gentle and careful. Everything is like a festival. He notices everything. Well, she is clearly
她的演艺事业。所以你刚才说她演过亚历山大皇后。她还演过伊丽莎白一世女王。因为她是权贵的女朋友。这对她的事业有帮助。是的。她把自己看作是好莱坞电影明星。我想她也想展现出那种形象。所以这就是穷人版的肯尼迪和玛丽莲。是的。某种程度上来说。此时完全看不出她是一个特别有政治头脑的人，也看不出庇隆是以这种眼光看待她的。所以她评价庇隆说，他棒极了，既坚强又温柔，温和而又体贴。一切都像节日一样。他注意到了一切。好吧，她显然
completely infatuated with Peron. Yeah, fine. But when we say she said that, her ghostwriter says that. There's no reason to doubt that he is an attentive boyfriend. I think that's fair to say. But I think the key thing is that actually she really believes in his message. So Peron has positioned himself as the champion of the working classes and in particular of the people who are called the gracitas, the greasers. So people who have come often from poor cities of Europe or from run-down rural towns and villages to Buenos Aires and they move in this world of the cheap B&Bs and the lodging houses. Which is the Eva world.
对庇隆完全着迷了。好吧，行吧。但当我们说这是她说的时，其实是她的代笔作家说的。我们没有理由怀疑他是一个体贴的男友。我觉得这样说挺公允的。但我觉得关键在于，她实际上真的坚信他的理念。因此，庇隆将自己定位为工人阶级的捍卫者，特别是那些被称为“油腻者”（gracitas）的人的捍卫者。这些人通常来自欧洲贫穷的城市，或是破败的乡村城镇和村庄，他们来到布宜诺斯艾利斯，混迹于廉价的B&B旅馆和客栈的世界中。这就是伊娃的世界。
It is her world. There's no doubt in my mind, when he talks about, I will lift up the masses, I will do all that, and she, his girlfriend, is listening. She's like, that's me. This is the period when she plays the part of the woman in that radio drama that we opened this episode with. Yeah, exactly. If this, as you said, is being broadcast across the country
这是她的世界。毫无疑问，当庇隆谈到“我将提升大众，我将做到这一切”时，作为他女朋友的她正在聆听。她的感觉是，这就是我。也就是在这个时期，她在我们这期节目开头播放的那部广播剧中扮演了一个女性角色。是的，完全正确。如果正如你所说，这些内容正在全国各地播放
in squares and so on, then her voice praising this one man who can bring dignity to the notion of work, a soldier of the people, who can feel the flame of social justice, she is the voice of that Peronist propaganda. And she's being joined in the kind of public imagination with him. Yeah.
在广场等等地方，那么她的声音就是在赞美这个能赋予劳动概念尊严的独一无二的男人、一个人民的士兵、一个能感受到社会正义火焰的人，她就是庇隆主义宣传的声音。她在公众想象中开始与他联系在一起。是的。
And when she says there was only one man and all that, she loves that. She loves being the standard. And what a big thing for her, the girl from nowhere, who is the propaganda vehicle for the coming man in Argentine politics. The interesting question is when she stops to see herself purely as a vehicle, but as a kind of political actor in her own right, we get some sense from the way in which she presents herself in 1945. It's a slow process because at first she starts to get a lot of interviews she's perron's girlfriend and you know she's on the radio and stuff and at first in those interviews
当她说“世上只有一个男人”之类的话时，她非常喜欢这样。她喜欢成为标杆。对于这个来自社会底层的女孩来说，能够成为阿根廷政坛一颗冉冉升起的新星的宣传工具，这是一件多么了不起的事。有趣的问题是，她什么时候开始不再把自己仅仅看作一个工具，而是看作一个具有独立政治行动能力的个体呢？从她在1945年的表现中，我们能察觉到一些端倪。这是一个缓慢的过程，因为起初她开始接受大量采访，她是庇隆的女朋友，你知道的，她在广播里露面等等，最初在这些采访中
it's pure hollywood cliche so she says i like riding horses i speak french i love reading tolstoy no dominic no Do you know who her favourite author was? Tom? She said her favourite author was. If you don't know it, you will never guess. It's Plutarch. Okay. The second century Greek biographer.
这纯粹是好莱坞的老套路，所以她说我喜欢骑马，我会说法语，我爱读托尔斯泰。不对，多米尼克，你知道她最喜欢的作家是谁吗？汤姆？她说她最喜欢的作家是。如果你不知道，你永远也猜不到。是普鲁塔克。好吧。这位公元二世纪的希腊传记作家。
Now, you know why she says that? Because Peron is its favourite author. Because Peron taught Plutarch and he was obsessed with Plutarch. I mean, she says, oh, I love Plutarch. I don't think she'd ever read Plutarch. I don't mean to be mean to her, but there are doubts. But then in February 1945, there was something that I think is really, really revealing. There were shortages of film stock because of the Second World War.
现在，你知道她为什么这么说吗？因为庇隆最喜欢的作家就是他。因为庇隆教过普鲁塔克，而且他对普鲁塔克着迷。我的意思是，她说，哦，我爱普鲁塔克。我不认为她读过普鲁塔克。我不是故意刻薄她，但确实存在疑问。但随后在1945年2月，发生了一件我认为非常、非常能说明问题的事情。由于第二次世界大战的原因，电影胶片短缺。
So they can't get hold of film. And to make films, you have to get the stock and all this. She, because she's Perron's girlfriend, can do this. She gets all this film and she says, this is the film I want to make and it's a film called La Prodiga, The Prodigal, The Prodigal Woman. And it's a film about a sort of ageing beauty in Spain who lives in this village and she does good works for the poor. There's a dam being, it sounds like a terrible film,
所以他们弄不到胶片。要拍电影，你得有胶片库存诸如此类的东西。她因为是庇隆的女朋友，所以能办到。她弄到了所有这些胶片，并且说，这就是我想拍的电影，片名叫《浪子回头》（La Prodiga，《浪子》或《浪子女性》）。这部电影讲的是西班牙一个村庄里一个有点年老色衰的美人，她在村里为穷人做好事。那里正在修建一座水坝，听起来像是一部烂片，
there's a dam being built near the town brilliant where the young engineer handsome young engineer she falls in love with the engineer thanks to her relationship with the engineer she's known as the
镇附近正在修建一座水坝，太棒了，那里有一位年轻的工程师，英俊的年轻工程师，她爱上了这位工程师，由于她与工程师的关系，她被称为
mother of the poor and she's giving booties to small children or whatever she's doing and then at the end of the film the dam is finished the engineer goes back
穷人的母亲，她给小孩子送婴儿鞋或者做别的事情，然后在电影结束时，水坝建成了，工程师回去了
forgets about her somehow her land and her house have been mortgaged to pay for her good works and so she kills herself herself. That is the story of this film. It sounds like a rubbish film. She chooses this of all the subjects. She could have played Elizabeth I. She could have done whatever she wanted. She says, no, I want to play this miserable woman who's very kind to the poor and then ends up taking her own life. What could be more revealing? That of all things, this is the thing that she wants to do.
把她忘得精光，不知怎的，她的土地和房子都被抵押了用来支付她做慈善的费用，于是她自杀了。这就是这部电影的故事。听起来像是一部垃圾电影。在所有这些题材中，她偏偏选了这个。她本可以扮演伊丽莎白一世。她本可以做任何她想做的事。她说，不，我想扮演这个对穷人很好、最后却选择结束自己生命的悲惨女人。还有什么比这更能说明问题的呢？在所有事情中，这就是她想做的事。
And I think that is a sign there in early 1945 when she's making this film. She is actually, she wants to almost become Peron's message. You know, she's to live it. Well, she casts herself, doesn't she, as the bridge between Peron and the people. She's kind of Peron is God the Father and she's like the Holy Spirit.
我认为这是1945年初她拍摄这部电影时的一个迹象。实际上，她几乎想成为庇隆的讯息本身。你知道的，她要活出这个讯息。好吧，她把自己塑造为庇隆与人民之间的桥梁，不是吗？庇隆就像是圣父上帝，而她就像是圣灵。
Exactly, yeah. Significant Christian figure that Eva will start impersonating. I actually thought that would really appeal to you. Anyway, this film is overtaken by events because in 1945, obviously, everyone knows 1945, the end of the Second World War. And people in the Argentine military, as we said before, they kind of like the Germans.
完全正确，是的。这是一个重要的基督教形象，伊娃后来开始模仿这个形象。我其实觉得这会非常吸引你。不管怎样，这部电影被时代的发展所超越了，因为在1945年，显然大家都知道1945年是第二次世界大战的结束。而正如我们之前所说，阿根廷军队中的人们，他们挺喜欢德国人的。
They obviously have massive links with Italy. Right. And so famously, this is where all the escaping Nazis head, isn't it? Right. There's lots of people in the Argentine military. They loved seeing Britain getting a beating at the beginning of the war. And they got it. The British win.
他们显然与意大利有着巨大的联系。没错。所以众所周知，这也是所有逃亡纳粹的去处，对吧？阿根廷军方有很多人。他们喜欢看到英国人在战争初期挨打。他们确实挨打了。英国人赢了。
And there's this sort of mood in the summer of 1945 oh that side they were backing is lost so they've got to go and the person who's really pushing this a man with one of the worst names i think we've ever had on the rest is history is the american ambassador who is a man called yeah how do you pronounce this i his name is i mean how would you introduce how do you pronounce this? His name is... I mean, how would you introduce yourself to people like this at a party? His name is... I can't even say it. Okay, well, let me see if I can work out how you say it.
1945年夏天弥漫着这样一种情绪：哦，他们支持的那一方输了，所以他们得走了。而真正推动这一进程的是一个名字糟糕透顶的人，我认为这是我们在《历史其余部分》节目中遇到过的最糟的名字之一，他就是美国大使，这个人名叫……等等，你该怎么发音呢？他的名字是……我的意思是，你该怎么介绍……你到底怎么发音？他的名字是……我甚至都说不出口。好吧，那我看看我能不能琢磨出怎么发音。
Is it Spruill? Sprill? Spruillay? I think his name is Spruill Braden. Spruill. Spruill. Is it? I don't know. How would you say it? I mean, we may have listeners called Spruile? I think his name is Spruile Braden. Spruile. Spruile. Is it? I don't know.
是斯普鲁尔（Spruill）吗？斯普里尔？斯普鲁伊莱？我想他的名字叫斯普鲁尔·布雷登（Spruile Braden）。斯普鲁尔。斯普鲁尔。是吗？我不知道。你会怎么读？我的意思是，我们可能有些听众叫斯普鲁尔？我想他的名字叫斯普鲁尔·布雷登。斯普鲁尔。斯普鲁尔。是吗？我不知道。
How would you say it? I mean, we may have listeners called Spruile. I don't believe that. In which case, we should apologize. Such people wouldn't listen to the rest of history. But that is a mad name. Spruile Braden. He's an enormous man.
你会怎么读？我的意思是，我们可能有些听众叫斯普鲁尔。我才不信呢。要是真有，那我们得道歉了。这样的人才不会听《历史其余部分》呢。但这个名字太疯狂了。斯普鲁尔·布雷登。他是个身材魁梧的人。
He's the heir to a copper fortune in Chile. Oh, brilliant. So he's the embodiment of Yankee imperialism. Totally. With his laughable name. Rising up out of Peronist nightmares. And Spurl Braden, hanging around in the polo clubs of Buenos Aires.
他是智利一个铜业大亨的继承人。哦，太棒了。所以他就是洋基帝国主义的化身。完全是。带着他那个荒谬的名字。从庇隆主义的噩梦中崛起。而斯普鲁尔·布雷登则在布宜诺斯艾利斯的马球俱乐部里闲逛。
Trampling over shirtless peasants as he walks out to his Rolls Royce. He says, this bloke Peron is a terrible man. He's got to go. He's obviously a Nazi. And Spurl Bradaden is crossing the country meeting liberal politicians and saying oh these army officers are dreadful people you got to change if you want to get in with the us get a kind of more liberal it's kind of civilian
当他走向自己的劳斯莱斯时，脚下践踏着赤膊的农民。他说，这个叫庇隆的家伙是个混蛋。他必须滚蛋。他显然是个纳粹。而斯普鲁尔·布雷登则在全国各地奔走，会见自由派政治家，并说道，哦，这些军官太可怕了，如果你想讨好美国，你就得做出改变，换成一个更开明的、某种文职
government get some of the old polo players rugby people back brilliant do all that so by the summer of 1945 it's a very fran sort of what's the word i was about to say it's frizzled that's not the right word it's frazzled spruill braden has driven me mad fraught and frazzled it is it's fraught and frazzled and um perron himself is going and giving speeches and he is saying there's an alliance of foreign reactionaries and plutocrats who are trying to bring us down he's not wrong he's not wrong he's not wrong at all. So everything, everyone's got very excited. And then on the 9th of October, and it's such a sort of tiny thing that's the trigger, they appoint a new communications secretary in the government.
政府，把一些老马球手、橄榄球手找回来，太棒了，把这些都做完。所以在1945年夏天，这是一个非常……怎么说呢，我刚才正要说“friszzled”，这不是个正确的词，是“frazzled”（疲惫不堪的），斯普鲁尔·布雷登把我逼疯了，“fraught and frazzled”（充满焦虑与精疲力竭），确实是充满焦虑与精疲力竭，而且……庇隆本人到处去发表讲话，他说有一群由反动派和财阀组成的外国同盟正试图推翻我们，他没说错，他没说错，一点也没说错。所以一切，所有人都非常兴奋。然后在10月9日，引发这一切的导火索竟然是一件如此微不足道的小事，他们在政府中任命了一位新的通信秘书。
And this is a bloke who's a friend of Ava's. He's like an old contact of Ava's. Clearly, you know, Perron has done her a favor. And the job had been promised to an army officer in a garrison outside the city. And he's gutted not to have got the job had been promised to an army officer in a garrison outside the city and he's gutted not to have got the job and lots of the other army officers say you know what this is this flipping awful woman you know she's got peron's ear if we're not careful you know he'll give all her mates jobs and we there won't be any jobs for us well hasn't he already given ava's brother juan a job as his secretary he has. So Juan is a generally disliked man, I think,
这家伙是伊娃的朋友。他是伊娃的老熟人。显然，你知道的，庇隆卖了她一个人情。而这个职位原本是承诺给城外一个驻地的军官的。没能得到这份工作让他感到极其沮丧，原本答应给城外驻地军官的工作泡汤了，他为此懊恼不已，许多其他军官也纷纷表示，你知道吗，这个该死的讨厌女人，你知道她掌握着庇隆的耳边风，如果我们不小心，你知道的，他会把所有工作都分给她的狐朋狗友，那我们就没有工作可做了。好吧，难道他没有已经给伊娃的弟弟胡安安排了秘书的工作吗？他确实给了。所以胡安是个普遍不受欢迎的人，我想，
as Feds has said. And he has indeed. And there's a sort of sense. Now, of course, this is how politics, how Archantime politics works. It works on patronage networks. But they are the wrong people. They're a parvenu family.
正如费兹所说的那样。他的确如此。而且有一种感觉。当然，政治就是这样运作的，阿根廷政治就是这样运作的。它是建立在裙带关系网之上的。但他们选错了人。他们是一个暴发户家庭。
They're the Woodvilles, Tom, of the Wars of the Roses. And the old guard in the army, well, not the old guard, young officers are like this bike's giving all this and one of them says we were convinced it was our duty to stop the nation from falling into the hands of that woman as in fact ultimately happened i mean they're not wrong right that it is going to fall effectively into the hands of ava and her friends. In a very complicated and frankly, slightly tiresome series of machinations, Peron is forced to resign. And he resigns in a style that will become emblematic of Peronism. So he goes to the secretaries of labor and he gives this speech to this huge crowd whipped up
汤姆，他们就像是玫瑰战争中的伍德维尔家族。军队中的老派人物——呃，其实不是老派，是年轻军官们觉得这家伙把所有这些都给了……其中一个人说，我们坚信阻止国家落入那个女人之手是我们的职责，正如最终确实发生的那样。我的意思是，他们没说错，对吧，国家确实最终基本上落入了伊娃和她的朋友们手中。在一系列复杂且坦白说有点烦人的阴谋诡计之后，庇隆被迫辞职。他辞职的方式后来成了庇隆主义的象征。他去找劳工秘书，向聚集在工会煽动下的巨大群众发表了这番演讲：
by the trade unions where he says, we win in one year we'll win in 10 years who knows but we will win i'm not going to say farewell to you i will say hasta siempre until the end of time until forever because from this day onwards i will be with you closer than ever this is the absolute tone i would be out on the street sobbing yeah people have burst into tears the thing is what i always think about all these speeches, and indeed, every speech that Peron and Ava ever give,
他说，我们赢了一年，十年后我们也会赢，谁知道呢，但我们一定会赢。我不会对你们说再见，我会说“hasta siempre”（直到永远、直到时间的尽头），因为从今天开始，我将比以往任何时候都更紧密地与你们在一起。这就是绝对的基调。我要是听了得跑到街上号啕大哭。是的，人们都泪流满面了。问题是，每当我想起这些演讲，以及庇隆和伊娃发表过的每一次演讲时，
it doesn't mean anything. No, but it's the mood. What does that even mean? I will be with you forever. Yeah. It's the vibe, as you said. It's the mood. Do you know what I would do?
这些话根本没有任何实际意义。不，但关键是那种氛围。这到底是什么意思？我将永远与你们在一起。是的。正如你所说，这是一种感觉。这是一种氛围。你知道我会怎么做吗？
What would you do? If there was any prospect of him, say, appearing on the balcony of the Casa Rosada, I would go and stand beneath it and gaze up rapturously. Yeah, you'd go. That's what I'd do. If you did that in the 70s, a bomb would go off and you it and gaze up rapturously. Yeah, you'd go. That's what I'd do.
你会怎么做？如果他有可能出现在玫瑰宫的阳台上，我会去站在阳台下方，入迷地仰望着他。是的，你会去的。这就是我会做的。如果你在70年代这么做，就会有炸弹爆炸，而你……仰望着他。是的，你会去的。这就是我会做的。如果你在70年代这么做，就会有炸弹爆炸，你会被炸死的。
If you did that in the 70s, a bomb would go off and you'd be killed. Yeah, but it isn't. It's the 40s, isn't it? So it'd be fine. Yeah, so you're right. Then, more weird machinations.
是的，但现在不是70年代。这是40年代，对吧？所以不会有事的。是的，你说得对。接下来是更多离奇的阴谋。
Peron ends up being arrested and taken to this island in the middle of the River Plate Delta sort of between Argentina and Uruguay. So, having watched the musical, I know what happens next,
庇隆最终被捕，并被带到了阿根廷和乌拉圭之间拉普拉塔河三角洲中间的一个小岛上。所以，看过了音乐剧之后，我知道接下来会发生什么，
which is that Ava rouses the streets, doesn't she? And pledges a new Argentina. But I know, I know Dominic, because I know your ways. I know your methods. That you were going to ruin that, aren't you? You're going to tell me it never happened. Yeah, I'm going to stamp on that, Tom, and tell you that didn't happen at all. So actually, you're absolutely right. In Peronist propaganda, and indeed, interestingly, in anti-Peronist propaganda. Because they are saying that he's a wimp.
那就是伊娃煽动街头群众，对吧？并誓言建立一个新的阿根廷。但我知道，多米尼克，我了解你的套路。我了解你的方法。你肯定会毁掉这个情节，对吧？你会告诉我这根本没发生过。是的，汤姆，我要彻底否定这一点，告诉你这根本没发生过。所以实际上，你说得完全没错。在庇隆主义的宣传中，以及有趣的是，在反庇隆主义的宣传中也是如此。因为他们认为他是个懦夫。
He's a puppet of a woman. And this terrible woman rouses the streets to rescue this weakling of a man. Yeah. That is just not right. Ava doesn't have the contacts. Who's she going to rouse? A lot of radio actors and the sound engineers from the radio company. But you know the idea that it's ava who pulls this out that perron wants to give up you know that he wants to find job satisfaction in paraguay as
他是女人的傀儡。而这个可怕的女人煽动街头群众去营救这个懦弱的男人。是的。这根本不是真的。伊娃根本没有那么广的人脉。她能煽动谁？一帮广播剧演员和广播公司的音响工程师。但你知道那种认为正是伊娃力挽狂澜、庇隆想要放弃的想法——正如蒂姆·赖斯所说，
tim rice puts it yeah i mean what that casts him as is justinian and ava as kind of theodora and i was thinking that there is a quality of theodora to Ava. So Theodora is the- Also called a prostitute, right? Called a prostitute, but actress, circus performer, who marries Justinian, the emperor in Constantinople. There's kind of riots and things, and it looks as though the empire will fall, and Theodora stands by him and goes on to become a saint.
他想在巴拉圭找到工作满足感——是的，我的意思是，这把庇隆塑造成了查士丁尼，而把伊娃塑造成了狄奥多拉，我一直在想，伊娃身上确实有一种狄奥多拉的特质。所以狄奥多拉是——也被称为妓女，对吧？被称为妓女，但她是个女演员、马戏团演员，嫁给了君士坦丁堡的皇帝查士丁尼。当时发生了一些暴乱之类的事情，帝国看起来要崩溃了，而狄奥多拉坚定地支持他，后来被封为圣徒。
And there's a quality of Theodora to Ava, don't you think? Oh, that had not occurred to me tom but that is a great point this is exactly that story right this is the story of the nica riots yeah in whenever it was the mid-sixth century this is exactly what happens although i think theodora did stiffen justinian's resolve and this and ava doesn't because perron is he knows what he's doing he's operating from background. Well, he's got loads of supporters by now. He's got the unions, hasn't he? In the unions.
你不觉得伊娃身上有一种狄奥多拉的特质吗？哦，汤姆，我之前没想到这一点，但你这个观点太棒了。这完全就是那个故事，对吧？这就是尼卡暴动的历史，不管是在公元六世纪中叶的什么时候，这正是发生的事情。尽管我认为狄奥多拉坚定了查士丁尼的决心，而伊娃没有，因为庇隆他知道自己在做什么，他一直在幕后运筹帷幄。好吧，他当时已经有了大批支持者。他有工会，不是吗？掌控着工会。
And the unions, his pals at the CGT, which is the big union organisation, they say, let's have a general strike. Poor old Peron, our great pal. Let's get people to march on the presidential palace, the Casa Rosada, to show their love for Peron. Now, it's the 17th of October. It becomes the big day, loyalty day day in the Peronist calendar. October is the beginning of the Argentine summer. And because of that, it's a really lovely sunny
工会，他在CGT（总工会，也就是那个大型工会组织）的伙伴们说，我们举行一次总罢工吧。可怜的庇隆，我们伟大的朋友。让我们号召人们游行前往总统府玫瑰宫，以表达他们对庇隆的热爱。现在是10月17日。这一天成了庇隆主义日历上的重大日子——忠诚日。十月是阿根廷夏季的开始。正因为如此，这是一个非常美好的晴朗日子，
day and lots of workers leave their factories. And especially these are people from the edge of the city who don't normally go into the middle of the city. So you're kind of Borges type people and indeed Spruill Braden, who are kind of, you know, they're toasting Peron's Fall. With bourbon. Yeah, or with a large glass of Moulvac. At the country club. Exactly, at the club.
许多工人离开工厂。尤其是那些来自城市边缘、平时不怎么去市中心的人。所以你们这些博尔赫斯式的人物，以及斯普鲁尔·布雷登，他们（在某种程度上）正在庆祝庇隆的倒台。喝着波旁威士忌。是的，或者在高尔夫俱乐部里喝着一大杯马尔贝克红酒。没错，在俱乐部里。
And they look out of the window and like, who are all these people? The Great Unwashed. And one of the accounts says they are literally smaller and darker than the people who usually walk down these central streets in Buenos Aires. These are people from the Cinturón Obrera, the workers' belt around the city. You've come into the middle of the city. The authorities are totally taken by surprise. They would, in other circumstances, have called in troops
他们向窗外望去，心想：这些人都是谁？底层下水道的穷人。其中一份记录甚至说，他们的身材确实比平时在布宜诺斯艾利斯市中心散步的人更矮小、肤色更深。这些人来自“工人地带”（Cinturón Obrera），即环绕城市的工人阶级地带。你们来到了市中心。当局完全被打了个措手不及。在其他情况下，他们本可以调集首都郊区驻地的军队，
from the garrisons outside the capital. But the streets are so full of people, the troops could not even get through if they were called in. And so, by that afternoon of the 17th of October, there are huge crowds in the center of Buenos Aires. I mean, hundreds of thousands of people outside the Casa Rosada calling for Perón. You can see the poverty written in their bodies. You can indeed. La Iqueva was La Flaca, wasn't she? The thin one as a girl. Yeah. These are Las Flacas, Los Flocos. Yeah. The skinny ones. Yeah, exactly. yeah it's our las flacas los flocos yeah the skinny ones yeah exactly and
但街上的人实在太多了，即使调动军队也根本无法通过。因此，到了10月17日下午，布宜诺斯艾利斯市中心聚集了庞大的群众。我是说，玫瑰宫外有数十万人高呼庇隆的名字。你能从他们的身体上看出贫困的痕迹。确实如此。伊娃以前不是叫“瘦子”（La Flaca）吗？小时候是个瘦女孩。是的。这些人就是“瘦子们”（Las Flacas, Los Flacos）。是的。那些骨瘦如柴的人。是的，完全是。是的，确实是我们的“瘦子们”，那些骨瘦如柴的人，是的，完全如此。而且
it's hot it's a hot day and as people do they're football fans celebrating the center of a capital they jump into the fountains and things and splash around and they take off their shirts and so this is where the famous phrase comes from yes the des camisados the shirtless ones originally an insult and then embraced by Peron and his supporters. Like the sans-culottes. Yeah. People with no trousers. I mean, it has that element, doesn't it?
天气很热，这是一个炎热的日子，人们像平常一样——作为庆祝首都中心的足球迷——跳进喷泉里嬉戏打闹，脱掉了衬衫，著名的词组“无衬衫者”（descamisados）就是这么来的。是的，无衬衫者。最初是个贬义词，后来被庇隆和他的支持者们欣然接受。就像法国大革命时期的无套裤汉（sans-culottes）。是的。没裤子穿的人。我的意思是，确实有那种成分，不是吗？
Because it's not just the idea that you are so poor that you can't even afford a shirt. It's also hovering in the background of that word. Yeah, exactly. So Peron finally is brought out onto the balcony. He's made up with the president and with all the other offices. I thought you were going to say he's made up his face to cover his rash. But presumably he's done that as well. He's making up in all kinds of ways.
因为这不仅仅是说你穷得连一件衬衫都买不起的概念。那个词的背景含义中还隐约包含着别的意思。是的，完全如此。所以庇隆终于被带到了阳台上。他和总统以及其他所有官员言归于好。我以为你要说他化了妆是为了遮住皮疹。不过想必他也顺便化了妆。他方方面面都化了妆。
He undoubtedly has. If you're thinking there are some very strange details, episode five or whatever is off the charts. Six, ten, whatever. It's going to be off the charts. Perron turns up on the balcony everyone starts crying and there are wonderful descriptions of the crowd there is a quality from this point onwards in argentine politics i don't know enough about the what
他毫无疑问是化了的。如果你觉得这里面有一些非常奇怪的细节，第五集还是什么的简直不可思议。第六集、第十集什么的。绝对会离谱到极点。庇隆出现在阳台上，每个人都开始哭泣，对当时人群的描述简直妙不可言。从这个时刻开始，阿根廷政坛涌现出一种特质——我对它之前的历史了解不够，无法得知这种特质是否原本就存在——那就是一种难以置信的戏剧化特质，每个人都把自己的情绪煽动到无以复加的狂热状态。我的意思是，这一天并没有人死。这不是枪战或街头巷战。所以从某种意义上说……
preceded it to know whether it was already there but there is a quality of just the unbelievably histrionic that everybody is whipping themselves into the most immense lava. And I mean, people don't die on this day. This is not like a shootout or a street battle. So actually, in a sense... But it becomes kind of part of the myth in due course, isn't it, that people had died, as we will find out when we look at what was planned for Avers 2,
但在适当的时候，它成了神话的一部分，就像我们在探讨为伊娃举行第二次葬礼的计划时会发现的那样，人们想要那天死难者的骨灰。但其实并没有死人。是的。根本不存在。但显然，这个神话至少变得与实际结果同等重要。确实如此。正如我们一直所说的那样，在这个神话中，伊娃扮演了压倒一切的角色。所以有两个问题。
that they wanted the ashes of someone who died on this day. And there wasn't anyone. Yeah. It didn't exist. But obviously the myth of it becomes at least as important as the practical consequences. It absolutely does. And in that myth, as we've been saying, Ava comes to play an overwhelming role. So two questions.
首先，伊娃在这其中到底做了什么？其次，在关于这件事的神话叙事中，她被赋予了什么角色？所以在神话叙事中，是伊娃煽动了群众。是伊娃走遍了布宜诺斯艾利斯的工厂——我太久没看过那部电影了。那个女人。
Firstly, what was Ava actually doing in this? And secondly, what is the role that she is given in the kind of mythic account of it? So in the mythic account of it, it is Ava who whips up the crowd. It's Ava who goes around the factories of Buenos Aires so long since I saw that film. The woman.
是的。我不知道里面是不是有什么蒙太奇之类的镜头，但应该有。确实有。那是一个新的阿根廷，她走过街道，人们都在欢呼，挥舞着红旗之类的东西。好吧，不是红旗，但他们挥舞着阿根廷国旗。这就是那个形象。当天的事件经过了重新书写，将她置于核心地位。
Yeah. I don't know if there's like some sort of montage or something, but there should be. There is. It's a new Argentina and she's walking through the streets and they're all cheering and waving red flags and things. Well, not red flags, but they're waving Argentine flags. And this is the image. The events of the day were rewritten to put her at the center of it.
这就是神话。当时根本没有任何证据表明发生过这种事。没有任何证据证明她当时甚至在场。我的意思是，我猜她可能在场吧。所以我们并不真正知道她在做什么。不，她在那个阶段还不是一个足够重要的人物。当然，她后来在这个时期变得极其重要。别忘了，她当时只是庇隆的女朋友。走上阳台的是庇隆，而不是伊娃。他又发表了一场精彩的庇隆主义演讲。
That was the myth. There's no evidence from the time of that happening at all. There's no evidence she was even there. I mean, I'm guessing she might have been there. So we don't really know what she was doing. No, she's not significant enough a figure at that stage. She later, of course, becomes incredibly significant this time. Don't forget, she's just Perron's girlfriend. It's Perron who goes out, not with Ava, onto the balcony. And he gives, again, a brilliant Perronist speech.
他说，我想作为一个普通公民融入这群流着汗水的人民之中。我想像对待母亲一样把他们紧紧拥抱在我的心头。我唯一的野心就是得到你们的爱。然后所有人都开始哭泣。是的。我们录制这期节目的时候，正赶上里希·苏纳克宣布举行大选的那周。他站在雨中发表讲话，背景音乐播放着新工党的主题曲：事情会好起来的。
He says, I want to mix with this sweating mass as a simple citizen. I want to hug it close to my heart as I would my mother. My only ambition is to be loved by you. And everybody starts crying. Yeah. We're recording this the week that Rishi Sunar went out and announced the general election. And he stood there getting rained on while somebody played New Labour themes. Things are going to get better.
他本该采取全套的庇隆主义风格，不是吗？是的。他本该发表长篇大论，告诉大家他爱他们，然后号啕大哭，涂上防皮疹粉底，穿上饰带。我觉得，我的意思是，虽然可能大概还是不会赢，但他的胜算会更大一些。是的，这总比接下来要发生的事强吧。
He should have gone the full perron, shouldn't he? Yeah. He should have kind of ranted, told everyone he loved them, burst into tears, put on his anti-rash makeup, got on some braid. I think that, I mean, you know, probably still probably wouldn't win, but he'd have a better chance. Yeah, it's not like it's worse than what's going to happen.
不，我觉得奇怪的地方在于，这当然是民粹主义。这过于夸张了。但它不仅仅是民粹主义，对吧？是的。这总比接下来要发生的事强吧。不，我觉得奇怪的地方在于，这当然是民粹主义。这过于夸张了。但它不仅仅是民粹主义，对吧？是的。这是歌剧式的。我想是的。这就是歌剧式的。这是极致的感伤主义。
No, I think the weird thing, it's populist, of course. It's overwrought. But it's more than populist, isn't it? Yeah. It's not like it's worse than what's going to happen. No, I think the weird thing, it's populist, of course. It's overwrought. But it's more than populist, isn't it? Yeah. It's operatic. I guess so. It is operatic. It's ultra sentimental.
这就好比政治版的走上台去演唱一曲咏叹调。好吧，这正是你会做的事，而其余的就交给历史了，汤姆。好吧，确实如此。所以这也是为什么我内心深处对这一点有所共鸣。没错，显而易见。因为人群随后开始高喊那个成为庇隆政权赞歌的口号：明天是圣庇隆节（Mañana es San Perón）。
It's the political equivalent of going out and singing an aria. Well, that's the kind of thing you do and the rest is history, Tom. Well, exactly. So that's why part of me kind of responds to this. Right, clearly. Because the crowd then start chanting this thing that becomes an anthem of Perón's regime. Mañana es San Perón.
老板们干活去（Que trabaja el patrón）。意思是明天是圣庇隆日。明天，让老板们去干活吧。他们觉得，哦，真是首绝妙的赞歌，好极了的歌曲，伟大的情绪。然后他们都回家了。明天，也就是第二天，他们举行了一次声势浩大的总罢工。没有人去上班。他们都在喷泉里嬉戏，
Que trabaja el patrón. Which means tomorrow is Saint Perón's day. Tomorrow, let the bosses do the work. And they think, oh, brilliant anthem, great song, great sentiments. And they all go home. And tomorrow, the next day, they have a big general strike. Nobody goes to work. And they're all splashing. And tomorrow, the next day, they have a big general strike. Nobody goes to work.
高呼着庇隆的名字。他被释放了。所以他可以参加竞选了。他可以参加竞选了。现在，这里有一个简短的尾声，因为我们将在下一集中讨论竞选。我们将迎来庇隆和伊娃权力的巅峰。在那次10月17日之后的第五天——这一天现在成了庇隆主义的年度节日，他们会通过举行大型集会来庆祝——
And they're all splashing around in the fountain, chanting Peron's name. He's set free. And so he can run in the election. He can run in the election. Now, there is one quick coda to that, because we'll get to the election in the next episode. And we get to Peron and Ava at their apogee. Five days after this 17th of October, which now will become the annual feast day of Peronism, which they celebrate with these huge rallies.
你认为伊娃开始认同这一天以及“无衬衫者”，她自己也开始相信了吗？这是否也是促使她觉得自己与他们神秘地融为一体的一部分原因？我想是的。汤姆，我完全这么认为。是的。我认为当你审视她随后所有的言论时——不断呼唤“无衬衫者”，
Do you think the fact that Ava comes to be identified with this day and with the Des Camisados, does she come to believe it? Is that a kind of a part of what inspires her to feel that she's been mystically joined with them? I think so. I totally think so, Tom. Yeah. I think when you look at all her rhetoric in what follows the constant invocation of the descamizadas the
坚信自己是他们与庇隆之间的神秘纽带，是的，是这座桥梁——我不认为……也许她内心深处有一丝一毫对这套说辞的玩世不恭，但我真的不这么认为。我认为她绝对是深信不疑的。不，我不认为她有丝毫的玩世不恭。我的意思是，我觉得庇隆可能相当玩世不恭，但伊娃相信这一切。她深信不疑。不，我不认为她有丝毫的玩世不恭。我的意思是，我觉得庇隆可能相当玩世不恭。但伊娃相信这一切。她深信不疑的方式，就像罗纳德·里根深信那些关于老美利坚的故事一样，
belief that she is the mystical link between them and perron yeah the bridge i don't think that there might be a tiny sliver of her that is cynical about it but i don't really think there is i think she absolutely believes it no i don't think she's cynical at all i mean i think perron is quite cynical but i think ava believes everything she believes it. No, I don't think she's cynical at all. I mean, I think Peron is quite cynical. But I think Ava believes everything. She believes it in the way that Ronald Reagan believed those stories he would tell about the old America and
伟大的演员深信他们扮演的角色。是的。好吧，她不是个伟大的演员。在阿根廷的政治大舞台上，她扮演的是最伟大的角色。所有人当中最伟大的。哦，太棒了。所以在这次轰轰烈烈的大事五天后，他们结婚了。他们在公寓里结了婚。这是一场简短的民事婚礼。
great actors believe the part they play. Yeah. Well, she's not a great actor. On the public stage of Argentina, she plays the greatest role. Of all. Oh, very good. So five days after this big business, they get married. They get married in their apartment. It is a brief civil ceremony.
几乎所有细节都是虚假的、虚有其表的。他们声称是在她的家乡胡宁（Junin）结的婚，但实际上并没有。但她再也没回过那里，对吧？她没有回去。出生日期是假的。名字也是假的。她把自己的真实年龄填为23岁，而不是
And almost everything about it is false. Meretricious. So they claim they got married in Junin, her hometown, which they didn't. But she never goes back there, does she? She doesn't go back. The date of birth is wrong. And her name is wrong. She puts her real age as 23 rather
26岁。她说自己出生于1922年，而不是1919年。她填写的姓氏是杜阿尔特（Duarte）。毫无疑问，她为什么要这么做。这倒不是为了让自己看起来更年轻。她在这方面并不虚荣。实际上是为了能够使用她父亲的姓氏，而不是承认自己私生子的身份。几个月后，不知是谁——我们不知道是谁，但可以猜到——去了她出生的那个地方洛斯托洛斯（Los Tolos）。他们找到了户籍登记处，撕掉了她的出生证明，换上了一个虚假的日期和一个虚假的姓氏，给了她杜阿尔特这个名字。她从未向庇隆坦白过。
than 26. She says she was born in 1922 instead of 1919. And she puts her name as Duarte. And there is no doubt why she does this. It's not so that she can look younger. She's not vain about that kind of thing. It is actually so that she can claim her father's surname rather than admit her illegitimacy. And a few months later, somebody, we don't know who, but we can guess, goes to Los Tolos, the place where she had been born. They find the registry, they tear out her birth certificate, and they replace it with a false date and a false name, giving her the name of Duartes. She never admitted to Perón.
她从未告诉过他，她出生时用的是另一个名字。我的意思是，这绝对非同寻常。然而奇怪的是，恰恰因为她出身于社会最底层，才让她如此深受爱戴。但有时候人们会掩饰一些事情，而且，你知道的，这难道不是很奇妙吗？确实如此。
She never told him that she had been born under a different name. I mean, absolutely extraordinary. And yet the strange thing about that is that it's precisely the fact that she is from the very lowest echelons of society that will make her so loved. But there's something, sometimes people are ashamed of things, and, you know, isn't that so interesting? It is.
同样有趣的是，就在她更改姓氏的同时，她却费尽心机地去认领杜阿尔特这个姓氏。因为当然，随着婚礼的举行，她不再是伊娃·杜阿尔特了。她是伊娃·庇隆。她的童年并不是她唯一想要抹去的东西。在婚礼之后的几天里，在10月17日的大型集会之后，她演艺生涯的大部分证据都被销毁了。她收集了所有广播电台的宣传剧照并将其销毁。
And also interesting is that she is going to such lengths to claim the name of Duarte just as she is changing it. Because, of course, with the wedding, she's no longer Ava Duarte. She's Ava Perron. Her childhood is not the only thing she wants to erase. In the next few days after the wedding, after the big rally on the 17th of October, much of the evidence of her acting career is destroyed. She gets all the publicity stills from all the radio stations and she destroys them.
她去找那些摄影师——当然她有庇隆的势力作后盾。对于那些多年来为她拍过照片的摄影师，她索要底片并将其销毁。而那部电影《浪子》，只为她进行了私下放映，从未公映。显然，从这一刻起，伊娃·杜阿尔特已经死了，未来将属于政治家埃维塔·庇隆（Evita Perón）。这就是我们将在下一集中探讨的内容，如果你是“历史俱乐部”（The Restless History Club）的会员，你可以马上收听。如果你还不是会员又想收听，你可以访问therestlesshistory.com并在那里注册。如果不是的话，无论如何它很快也会发布。所以这算不上我做得好的营销，但这是事实。我们“历史·未完待续”节目一向注重真相，不像庇隆和伊娃。
She goes to the photographers and of course she has Perron's muscle behind her. To the photographers who've taken pictures of her all those years, she asks for the negatives and she destroys them. And that film, La Prodiga, it's shown privately to her and never released. It is clear that from this point onwards, Eva Duarte is dead and the future will belong to Evita Perón, the politician. And that is what we will be looking at in our next episode, which you can hear straight away if you are a member of the Restless History Club. If you're not and you would like to hear it, you can go to therestlesshistory.com and sign up there. And if not, it will be out very soon anyway. So that's not good marketing on my part, but it is true. And we're all about the truth on the Restless History, unlike Peron and Ava.
我们很快就会再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开
And we will see you very soon. Bye bye. Hasta luego. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q& q a we pull back the
娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及现场门票的优先购买权，请前往……该剧集目前尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权益，请前往……本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。